hello everyone
and welcome to today's broadcast
massively
parallel genome engineering followed by
pooled growth selections
for rapid target discovery and microbes
presented by dr laura clinton scientific
liaison
at inscripta my name is christy i'm from
lab roots
and i will be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational webcast is brought
to you by libraries and sponsored
by inscripta for more information on our
sponsor
you can click on the sponsor logo on the
left side of your screen
or visit inscripta.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that today's event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we will answer as many of your questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
also please notice you can share this
webinar on your personal social media
just click on the social sharing tab on
the left and let your friends and
colleagues know about today's live event
now if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of your presentation window
or just use that ask a question box to
let us know you're experiencing a
problem
i would now like to introduce today's
presenter dr laura clinton
dr clinton is a scientific liaison
within scripture's
emea team dr clinton is among other
tasks
responsible for correct and timely
communication between
internal and external partners and acts
as the voice of the customer
within inscripta to ensure outstanding
support and execution of projects
demonstrating the many
applications of the onyx digital genome
engineering platform
for a complete biography on dr clinton
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
welcome dr clinton you may now begin
your presentation
thank you to labroot for giving me an
opportunity to present our beautiful
data on massively parallel genome
engineering for rapid target discovery
in microbes
my name is laura clinton and it's my
pleasure to be here today
so the outline of today's talk is that
i'll start by giving you a brief
introduction to the onyx chemistry
just so everybody is on the same page
regarding the core technology and
principles for massive parallel genome
engineering
then i want to show you data on
responses to biomass inhibitors in e
coli
i'll show you how we generated more than
25 000 precise and trackable edits
across seven genome-wide libraries how
we then pooled all the cells and
performed growth selections
in 11 industrially relevant conditions
this pool growth selection resulted in
more than 800
000 data points and response patterns
and i'll show you um i'll show you how
we characterize this data for quality
and and broad response patterns
and and how we could create genotype
phenotype maps of responses in
inhibitory compounds
such as verbal and vanillin i'll end my
talk by showing you the onyx password
from how it works and how easy it is to
get started with onyx in your lab
but before i talk about inscriptive
technology and show you some of the data
we've generated
i want you to think about the promise of
the bioeconomy
the way we can use biology as
inspiration can fundamentally change
the way we produce different chemicals
for example fuels
polymers flavors and pharmaceuticals
however we still have a long way to go
for broad-scale implementation
since this concept were first introduced
around 20 years ago
in order for industry scale fermentation
to work and for the community to
increase the number and variety of
compounds
produced by fermentation we need high
efficient microbial strains
strains that are more tolerant of either
secondary byproducts
produced in the fermentation process or
even more importantly
the actual product of interest might be
toxic to the cells producing it
for example vanillin vanillin is an
important flavor compound
originally sourced from the seeds of the
vanilla plenifolia plant
however the industry demand for vanillin
greatly exceeds
the amount harvested from plants
currently aldehydes such as vanillin are
produced chemically
but there is an increased demand and
promise for more natural resource
compounds
especially within the food and flavor
market vandolin can be produced in high
performing and easy to engineer microbes
such as e coli
but since the compound is toxic for the
cells and in order to have increased
tidal and purity of the desired product
we need to modify and optimize the
genomes of the strengths
used for industrial scale fermentation
during this webinar i would like you to
grab pen and paper and start thinking
about how
you would design your experiments if you
could create 5000 edits per run
instead of five if you could create
libraries of both
genome-wide and rational single gene
changes in one go and if you were free
to select exactly the changes you wanted
to do
so having an increased scale increased
flexibility and increased diversity
i hope that by the end of this talk i've
shown you that doing all this is indeed
possible
not in the future but right now i hope
that many of you will send your ideas to
me
and we can certainly have a more
interactive brainstorm about which
projects you would do
if you had access to a technology that
would enable you to do all these things
scripta has developed a massively
parallel crispr based and multiplex gene
engineering system called the onyx
platform
the technology is powered by
inscriptor's own proprietary med-7
which is a cat-12a family member it's a
programmable endonuclease and it cuts
double-stranded dna when assembled with
the appropriate guide rna
mat 7 has a distinct and different
pamphlet than cas9
and inscriptive mission is to
democratize genome engineering
in order for the community to be able to
fulfill the promises of the bioeconomy
we've thus made math 7 free to use for
any commercial and non-commercial r d
work
you can download the sequence from our
website and start expressing it in your
systems today
but please stay for now and see the
beautiful data i'll present to you in
this webinar
and do not hesitate to write me directly
or contact us via our website if you
have any questions related to math 7 or
to onyx
the foundation and core technology was
invented by one of our co-founders
andrew garst who has found many years
been interested in how to scale up and
generate libraries for faster and
cheaper genome engineering
this foundational work was published
online in nature biotechnology in
december 2016.
it shows how guide rna and donor arm is
covalently linked
in order to make sure that the correct
guide and donor always are transformed
into the same cell
this principle makes it possible to
multiplex guide and donor pairs
and thus increase precise editing by
homology directed repair mechanism
as you can see many others have come up
with similar ideas from multiplex
library generation
in approximately one and a half years
later
in the spring of 2018. confirming the
tremendous
impact multiplex crispr editing
libraries have on the community
so the core and fundamental symbol yet
very elegant concept
is the ability to covalently link guide
rna with donor dna and a barcode for
tracking
we are thus moving away from a
well-based partition
to the single cell partition so
normally you would add the guide rna and
the donor template
as two separate molecules and in order
to make sure
that they are both transformed into the
same cell you would need to have vials
or wills as the partition
what inscriptor is doing is having each
individual guide rna covalently linked
to the appropriate donor dna and a
barcode for tracking
this concept makes it possible to
multiplex all the editing plasmids
and by the unique microfluidics in the
onyx platform
make sure that each guide rna donor and
barcode will go into each individual
cell
i want to stress here that the barcode
stays on the plasmid
and it's only the specific edit which is
being
incorporated into the genome this
fundamental principle of covalently
linked guide rna
donor and barcode together with the
microfluidics in the onyx
gives new possibilities for running
trackable libraries in bulk
and overcome the need for large 96 world
equipment style setup
we are those increasing the edits that
we can perform in one experiment
from 96 to thousands of edits at the
same time
the reason why we're doing all this this
is because we acknowledge
that there is a gap in what synthetic
biologists want to investigate and what
is currently technically possible to do
so currently genome-wide methods exist
as you can see on the x-axis here
you can do classical mutogenesis
targeting many locations in the genome
however this is a non-controlled and
non-trackable method
it's also possible to generate
genome-wide knob out libraries
but here you are limited by the type of
mutations you can do
basically these libraries only contain
one edit type and that's a deletion
the variety of edit types are depicted
on the y-axis
you can of course also have many
different edit types for example in
saturation metagenesis studies
of one protein or a few in a pathway
what inscriptor offers is the
possibility to reach that upper right
quadrant
and perform both high variety of edit
types and as a genome-wide scale
and that is indeed what onix can do the
onyx platform is a full
end-to-end crispr based genome
engineering solution
which consists of software chemistry
unique microfluidics modules for the
single cell work
and a benchtop instrument that would do
all your wet lab editing for you
the output from the onyx instrument is a
vial that contains a heterogeneous
population of your edited cells
but i'll come back to that in the end of
my talk
so in here i'll just show you some real
life examples of different edit types
we've generated with onix
we can perform edits in both coding and
non-coding regions as well as high
variety of edit types
we did a 60 base per insertion of
promoters
and ribosomal binding sites in e coli
and we also did
as we also did in this study we
performed
38 base pair substitution in the
terminator region of yeast
and created multiple knockout libraries
by introducing
triple stop codon at either position 5
or 15 in each gene
and thus creating truncated proteins and
finally we used onyx to quickly and
really easily generate libraries of
saturated metagenesis
for investigation of single proteins of
pathways
and the beauty of this technology is
that you can mix and match
the different edit types into the
libraries
so in relation to what you can do with
your edited cell population after
editing on the onix
it's basically possible to move into
directions for phenotyping
you can pull all the cells and grow them
up in the presence of for example toxic
compounds
as we did in this current study or you
can plate out the cells
grow up individual colonies and measure
the compound you want an increase
tighter off it's also possible to
basically
split the cell population in two parts
and do
both so you find both mutations which
are giving higher tighter
as well as better tolerance against
inhibitory compounds
now i wanted to show the experiment we
did and the beautiful data we generated
in this study
where we look for mutations that would
be beneficial and give resistance to
biomass inhibitors
in order to transition from
petrochemicals
to a bio-based economy we need
cost-effective feedstocks
at scale unfortunately abundant raw feed
stocks such as lingual cellulose pose
multiple issues
they generally require extensive
pre-treatment to release fermentable
carbon resources
and multiple toxic compounds are
released along with the fermentable
carbon sources
so many decades of excellent work has
resulted in the discovery of resistance
pathways and mechanisms
to overcome toxic compound inhibition
however increased for increased
performance and production of new
compounds
and shifting process requirements there
is a need for rapid optimization at
scale
so here we show that decades of work can
be recapitulated in a few months with
the onyx platform
and we also showed that even for very
well studied inhibitory compounds
there are huge numbers of additional
genomic targets that could be
exploited to increase strain tolerance
so we designed genome-wide editing
libraries
and edited the cells with our onyx
chemistry
so what we did was to design a
twice two times knockout libraries by
substitution of triple stop codon at
position 5 and 15
of all the protein-coding genes in the e
coli genome
we then also wanted to see changes based
on difference in expression
and we designed five different libraries
where we took the constitutive promoters
of varying strengths
from the igm database and inserted each
promoter
in front of every gene in the genome
so what you can see here in the circus
plot is actually all the editing designs
that we generated in this seven
libraries
from nut out in red to the weakest from
the weakest and to the strongest
promoter
so i'm just showing you how we basically
made
seven different designs for each gene in
the e coli genome
and giving a total of more than 25 000
edits
after the cells were edited with onix we
took that heterogeneous cell population
and grew it up under selective pressure
so basically we pulled all our edited
cell populations from our five-time
promoter of varying strengths and the
two knockout libraries
we then alicorted the cells into shaking
flasks with different known toxic
compounds
ferfrol vanillin hydroxy methyl perforal
and laryngic acid
as well as a media control we also
included a gradient
of sodium chloride as osmotic stress is
also known to arrest growth
and we added a ph gradient to see how
the cell population behaves
in acidic as well as alkaline conditions
so as all were run in triplicates we ran
a total of
36 shaking flasks for 48 hours
and after the 48 hours of growth we
harvested the cells
extracted dna and created ngs libraries
for sequencing
so we know that it can be costly to run
ngs
in order to track the genomic edits so
inscriptor has developed a plasmid
barcode amplicon
ngs library prep kit in order to make a
quick and reliable measurement of how
the cell population behaves
i want to make it clear that the barcode
stays on the plasmid after editing
so once you've found your interesting
hit we recommend to confirm these with
whole genome sequencing
or with sequencing of amplicons from
that particular genomic location
in our data we see a very good
correlation between barcode hits and
genomic hits
so increased barcode counts will
correspond to more cells with that
individual edit
and thus a growth advantage for that
particular clone
fewer counts will represent reduced
number of cells from that clone
based on for example fitness effects and
we can quickly tell
which mutations are beneficial and which
are dimensional in a given condition
for sequencing we typically pool five
ngs libraries on each mythic run
thus sequencing seven runs on the my sig
with one time 75 base pair setting
for this study so here you can see how
the population
behaves in the control media it seems
like the stronger
promoters gives a bit of an advantage in
general
as the normalized counts are increasing
with increased promoter strength
so how do you go about and analyze 25
000 edits
first of all we want to assess the
quality and biological reproducibility
of the data
and then we determine a method to look
for differences in the data among
conditions
we look at genome-scale trends of
enrichment and depletion
and finally functionally assess the
enriched depleted genes
to confirm existing knowledge and reveal
new findings
we first map the barcode sequencing data
back to the genomic edits that we
designed as you see here in this table
in each row we have the independent
promoter or not out
and in the columns we have the
biological replicates and count data
from some of the treatment conditions
this gave us in total more than eight
hundred thousand data points
we first then checked the
reproducibility of the data
and see a very high general
reproducibility between the biological
replicates
we then compare across treatments and we
also see that different toxic compounds
are changing the cell population in
different ways for example
it immediately becomes clear that
perforal and vanillin
do not have the same effect on the
population as the data does not
correlate very well
between those treatments
if we just look at the data and how the
variance is observed
we see that the biological replicates
cluster together
and that the cell population separate
based on the stress conditions
we see that the cell population in
increased salt concentration
alters along the first component as well
as separation
on the acidity of the media when looking
at the ph gradient
it's clear that the cell population
grown in fertile is very different from
the other treatment conditions
including the hydroxymethoferforal as
the peripheral population strongly
separates on the second component
we can then take a genome-wide view of
how the toxic compounds are altering the
cell population
remember that our starting material was
the same bulk of cells
we then allocated into the shaking
flasks
so we generally see a difference in the
response based on vanillin or virtual
we typically see both conditions that
adding a very weak promoter in front of
all genes
does not really change the overall
population compared to the control media
however with stronger promoters we start
to see
clear changes depending on the um
[Music]
on the mutations and those are being
more clear so and when we look at the
not out libraries
i'll just show them here we do see clear
changes depending on the toxic compound
it seems that deleting these genes and
then adding adrenaline
does not really help on the phenotype
whereas in the furful experiment
we do see some interesting hits emerging
another factor for those specifically
interested
we also see specific patterns around the
origin of replication
that can be investigated further
the mechanism of peripheral toxicity is
schematically represented here
it's known that primarily is based on
starvation via the nadph depletion
nadph specific oxidoredictases reduce
perforal to the less toxic perforal
alcohol
these nadph dependent processes deplete
cellular nadph resulting in reduced
cellular growth
it's known that knockout of the gene
yqhd
encoding an alcohol dehydrogenase which
is an nadph-specific oxidorectase
rescues cellular growth as a knockout
forces peripheral detoxification
to occur with nadh specific oxidory
hydrocases
furthermore over expression of the pnta
gene
encoding the protein in atp
transhydrogenate subunit alpha
helps to alleviate nadph starvation and
will give a growth advantage
to these clones in the population
so when zooming in on one specific gene
we can look at how each of the edits we
did
changes perforal response if we look at
lactaldehyde redictate encoded by the
gene
pnta we see that adding a constitutive
medium strength to a motor
will enrich for this clone in the
population during performance treatment
if we compare the sequencing counts in
the control situation with the perforal
treatment
we can calculate the slope and thus have
a measurement
which will represent the biological
response this is indeed what we see here
the sequencing counts from the three
replicates in the control media
is shown on the lower right corner
whereas the number of cells harboring
this mutation
are enriched in the fearful condition as
seen on the left
the normalized barcode curve is shown on
the y-axis
if we then look at all the edits we did
on pnta we see that the two knockouts
behave in a similar way
with reduced counts in the virtual
condition compared to control
however looking at the promoters it
seems there is an optimum
with the medium strength promoter and
that it does not help to add an even
stronger promoter in front of pmta
thus it will give better data if you
actually check all types of mutations
instead of just assuming that a stronger
promoter would be more beneficial for
the cell
when we then look at the biological
response as log 4 changes for all genes
in the seven different conditions
the two knob outs and the promoter
insertions of increased strength
we see that we cannot based on this say
that knockouts are always deleterious
for the clones
asset for many genes seems to give a
growth advantage
if knocking out specific genes we've
highlighted pnta
pattern from before in this plot so you
can see whether the cells were depleted
or enriched in the population after
fertile treatment
when compared to the control condition
we can now cluster the different genes
on how they behave in the seven
different mutations
for this we use umap clustering to see
how each gene behave in the log out and
promote a ladder libraries
at the pca problem we looked at the
variants in each cell population based
on treatment
and here we look for genes that behave
similarly on the fertile treatment so
here we just show data from the furful
treatment
and see that genes cluster in over all
four ways
we observe other genes that behave as
tnta where the knockout of that gene is
a drawback for the cell
whereas increased promoter strength is
giving a growth advantage for that cell
in this cluster we find pnta and fuco
confirming what's seen in the literature
the gene ontology terms
showing up for this cluster of genes are
acetyl-transferase activity
general transcription and cell cycle
functions
in the other end of the spectrum we also
see that knockout of specific genes
seems to bring a growth advantage to the
cells when under furfural toxic stress
and adding a promoter in front of those
genes do not do any good for the cell
survival in the population
sometimes biology makes sense and
sometimes you get surprised about which
gene
behave like this so in this cluster of
genes
we find functions of carbohyde metabolic
processes
and nadph dehydrogenase activity
in the two remaining clusters we see
genes that are either uniformly giving a
growth advantage to the self
no matter what you do or uniformly have
a reduction
in growth so basically if you are
looking to figure out which mutations to
introduce into a strain
to make it more tolerant towards a toxic
compound
this type of data will guide you and
it's even possible to combine the
different types of edits
into the same cells thus increasing
resistance
at a whole new level but i'll come back
to that
if we look at all the edits we generated
to find significant changes over the
control condition
we find more than 3 000 mutations which
are changing the way
cells respond to peripheral based on
growth patterns
we for example find that two of the
high-strength promoters in front of pnta
has a positive effect when cells are
grown in fertile as well
as knockout of why qhd also gives a
growth advantage
so in all we confirm many previously
reported mutations
in our study as well as finding new hits
for increased resistance
towards peripheral toxicity
if we compare to what is already known
in the literature
our study confirms seven of eight
experimentally validated genes
as well as 253 of 370
predicted mutations from omics
experiments
with us in this study find almost 2
500 new mutations that have a growth
effect
upon peripheral toxicity
we can select the most prominent hits
which were enriched and thus showed the
highest fall changes between control and
peripheral treatment
based on this data we can now select our
most promising strain
revalidate it and use this as the
starting strain for next round of
diversity generation
for example by combining the winners or
simply do a second round of genome-wide
agnostic mutations
so we can perform combinatorial
optimization
this way we can quickly jump the fitness
ladder and dramatically increase
tolerance towards toxic compounds
or increase the titer of desired product
if that's what you want to optimize
it's of course also possible to do both
and we've actually done so
in a project where we optimized lysine
production
and looked for increased tolerance
against thialysin which is a toxic
biometabolite
in the lysine amino acid biosynthesis
pathway
so today i showed you data where we
designed and generated more than 25 000
precise and trackable edits
across seven genome scale libraries in a
really easy and intuitive way
we performed growth selection of these
libraries in 11 industrially relevant
conditions
we characterized more than 800 000 data
points
for quality and broad response patterns
we performed genotype phenotype maps
of response to inhibitory compounds
fertile and nanoli
and this study we confirmed existing
literature as well as discovered
hundreds of novel targets
for strain improvement
i want to now show you how easy it is to
create high throughput massively
parallel genome engineering libraries
with the onyx platform in your own lab
inscriptors onix platform supports all
areas of the design
generate test and learn cycle our online
software
called inscriptor designer will design
guide rna and donor dna pairs and assign
a unique barcode
you simply inform the software what
edits you want and where you want them
we've built an intuitive graphical user
interface
and if you are more bioinformatic savvy
you can also upload a csv
fireball order edit you want inscriptive
designer will provide a color code for
each design
based on more than 1 000 different
parameters
in order to guide you in relation to how
good each particular design
is you can then select the designs you
want and test
and we will manufacture the custom
reagents containing your specific guide
rna
donor dna and barcode in complete kits
to
drive genome engineering you will then
receive
the custom reagents and the
microfluidics consumables
which fit into the onyx benchtop
instrument that you have in your lab
the footprint of the instrument is very
small the instrument will take care of
all wetland parts of the editing
experiment
the on instrument editing takes 2-3 days
and the result is a heterogeneous cell
population
of minimum 1 times 10 to the 7th cell
we've developed ngs essays for both
immediate qc of the editing experiment
and for downstream analysis of the
population after phenotyping
once phenotyped it's possible to track
back any barcode sequencing to the
genome level
and upload this data into our online
encrypted resolver software
which will help you analyze experimental
results and thus guide you for the next
round of the gtl
cycle
i want to pause here and just explain to
you how inscriptor only calls
edits if they are complete and intended
you see here on the left panel an
example of what we mean by complete and
intended
in this experiment we wanted to change
the codon for tyrosine tac
to threonine act so even though we still
encode a treonum with aca
it's complete but it's not intended and
therefore not included in the metric
you can also see that we create
auxiliary edits in the pam and spacer
regions
to prevent recutting of the mat 7
endonuclease
here you see on the circus plot it's
just an example of one single guard rna
targeting chromosome 1 of a yeast genome
and with the height of the bar
indicating the editing rate and thus the
fraction of cells in the population
with a complete and intended edit on
that specific position
when comparing different metrics with
literature it's important to think about
what is meant by that metric
typically mechanisms of both
non-homologous and joining and homology
directed repair
are repo are reported as successful
editing
but when you move from single edits to
mass parallel libraries of guide rnas
we need to be able to exactly trust that
the edit we designed is also what we see
in the final population
therefore we only count edits repaired
by homology directed repair
at this specified genome position so
each guide will dependent on precision
and edit type behave a little
differently so an inscriptor reported
edit efficiency is the number of cells
in the cell population
which has a complete and intended edit
whereas the design is observed is
showing the number of designs we find in
the population
i'll just give you an example of what
these metrics mean
if you have fifty percent of yourself in
the library with complete unintended
edit
and the 99 design represented in the
library
of ten thousand designs we can per one
million output cells
expect to find five hundred thousand
cells in the population with a complete
and intended edit
of those 500 000 cells we will find
9900 editing designs at least
once
so here you see the specs of the onyx
platform the technology has been
developed for e coli in yeast
it's optimized for inscriptive standard
strains and we can also use custom
strains on the instrument
we perform one edit per cell and those
can be
insertions deletions and substitutions
and a combination
combination of those in the libraries
each library can generate from 100
to 10 000 edits for e coli and up to six
thousand edits for yeast
so if you want more edits as we did in
the data i just showed you
it's possible to pool cells from
different libraries and phenotype
everything together
the added efficiency is thirty but
varies from 15 to
75 depending on the specific library
produced
dna based editing libraries and other
reagent manufacturing
is three to four weeks and the on
instrument time is only two to three
days
so i just i want to end here by thanking
all my brilliant colleagues in the
applications development and product
development teams
who designed the experiment did the lab
work and
all the data analysis
and i just want to thank you for
attention and i'll be happy to take
any questions
thank you dr clinton for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of our webinar
now to our audience if you have any
questions you would like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
okay let's get started we have lots of
questions already coming in
dr clinton let's start with this first
one when tracking
genome edits using the plasmid barcode
how confident are you that the edit has
been made
so thanks uh christy um that's a great
question
um we are quite certain that the edits
are made but of course you cannot be 100
sure uh because uh as i said in the
presentation that
the barcode stays on the plasmid we
don't want the barcodes on
genome so we recommend to actually
reconfirm
that you have that genomic edit
especially if you have some interesting
strains that you
that you are looking for and you can do
that with whole genome sequencing you
can also do amplicon sequencing of that
particular
region if it's just a few edits but you
can actually we also developed a
pooled whole genome sequencing essay for
um
to actually do the whole pool
so it makes it really easy to see the
genomic edits
um yeah
very good thank you our next question
would it be possible to explain in a bit
more detail
how your editing protocol allow for the
generation of both a
high variety of edits and across the
genome
yeah so this is a basically very kind of
this
question is very kind of core uh
of the technology because that's
actually what onyx is about
it's to have that ability to do both and
the and that's why we've developed this
holistic
way of like end-to-end solution because
you need
very good guide rna design that's very
important to
to really get that and you need the
homology arm you need that to happen
very efficiently but you also need to
make sure that you're not uh
you know um introducing something that
you don't want
so we worked a long time actually to
develop this technology
so that's why we have the instrument
that is running in the lab and we have
the microfluidics components to make
sure that we do
that we are able to design these
thousands of edits in one library
and that that we can do both the
substitutions and the
insertions and the deletions and you can
basically
you can basically mix that up into every
library
and because this is working in single
cells that's the reason why
you can actually do this
thank you dr clinton our next question
are cells alive post-experiment
can you isolate them again for
large-scale fermentation
and how is the dna extracted for library
prep
for illumina seek yeah so
yes they are alive uh because we are
working with living cells and that's
what
this is all about uh and yes you can
also isolate them
afterwards so you can grow them up as
clonal isolates
and yes to actually be able to
to get that specific clone and grow that
up
for any like other experiments for
example if you want to do
uh like the next round of diversity
generation you can use that uh
strain and um it's also possible to
like if you want to do con if you want
to confirm your edits
you can actually also prepare like
create a small library if you for
example have
maybe 100 like clones that you found wow
these are really good
you can redo this on the onyx and then
grow up those cells because then you
have
more cells in your population which
harbors those kind of hundred edits
instead of
if you have a large library um you
because you need the high coverage you
will of course have fewer
cells which has that particular edit in
it
um but yes it's possible they are live
and you can isolate them
and the kit we did for this particular
study
was just a a standard uh
kaijin dna isolation kit
yeah but we do we've also made an
application note
with lots of more details around this
particular
data that i showed today and please let
me know if you want a copy of the
application note and
i will be very happy to send it to you
and there are lots of details
about how we you know the methods and so
on
dr clinton how will your method support
hit validation
if i want to reconstruct edits which
have shown to be enriched in pool
cultivation experiments
yeah so so i i talked about that a
little bit but
i think it's uh it's a important that
you can do like um validate your
if you for example have found you may a
number like
i don't know 100 hits or so you can
actually create a small library
on the onix in order to reconfirm this
and and and just do sequencing of those
uh
fewer uh different designs
um so it's also possible with
the math 7 in your lab to do that like
single like for any like single work but
but
since we are working so onyx is about
high throughput and this is about scale
up
so we would recommend to actually pick
the best 100 and then do
a small library for for validation and
to have
your sales with that particular edit
thank you do you plan to enable
insertions of large dna molecules
such as heterologist genes and pathways
on the annex platform
on the onyx platform yeah so
so this is a question that we we get a
lot and of course we we want to uh
be able uh to support larger inserts and
larger
larger inserts in in the future right
now the technology allows us
to do between 1 and 60 base pair
and the reason why it's we haven't just
said well you can do thousands is
because we want to make sure that this
is actually efficient
for every design that you're making so
has to be efficient for the whole
genome not just one particular region
but it has to be efficient
all over the genome it has to also that
the coverage of the different designs
has to be
they have to be well represented in the
library so
uh when you get yourselves that the
designs that you made
is actually also present in the cell
population so that's the reason why
we're not offering these large inserts
right at this
uh time point but this is something that
we're definitely looking at
and this is something that is on a
roadmap
to come thank you dr clinton
now we do have time for a few more
questions but i do want to let our
audience know
any questions we're unable to answer
live today
and additionally those that come in
during the on-demand period
they will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration okay let's
keep going
our next question genome-wide libraries
seem like a powerful approach to
diversity generation do you plan to
offer pre-made knockout libraries
yeah so so this is a great question
right at this point in time we actually
see that the need to
be able to mix and match the different
edit types so
basically i guess one of the things we
want is to
people to think about not being limited
by the the
way they want to do libraries and
so we're not at this point in time
offering any like pre-made libraries
because we want to make sure that people
understand
that this is actually a matter
for you to exactly design
i want this these nug outs and i also
want
these promoters or i want these uh like
this uh
saturation mutogenesis of that
particular protein
and you can mix all that into one
library and in order to do that we need
to
uh we need to have this as a custom
order
because every customer is different and
everybody is looking at different things
so but of course if you are if you are
working and you want to kind of have and
you have a lot of
the same types of libraries we could you
can certainly contact us and we can
figure out a way to
like having those uh kind of pre-made
uh so so that's definitely something we
can talk about but
uh right now it's not like an
off-the-shelf
offering and dr clinton
this question has come in a few times
can you apply this approach to other
organisms and
viral genomes yeah so this is a great uh
question so right now onyx is optimized
for
for e coli and saccharomyces vta
and and we want to make sure that the
the editing efficiency is high
and that the and that the coverage is is
also high so the design coverage
so right now you need to use one of
those organisms
as your um as your kind of
workhorse if you can call it like that
um
so if you for example have a human gene
or a
viral gene or you want to kind of look
at anything specific
you can you can work with that and do
heterologous expression in e coli for
example or in yeast uh so that's that's
the option we have at the moment
we are looking into which other species
should be made available on onyx but as
you can imagine
since this is biology and these are live
cells so
uh every time uh you you move into a new
organism you have to kind of optimize
the whole
the the the platform again for that
because it's very important for us this
is a high efficient and and very well
working
technology so uh so right now i would
recommend to
to see if you can kind of hydrologically
express
your proteins of interest into an e coli
or yeast
in order to actually have benefits
of the massive scale that onyx offers
thank you dr clinton and we have time
for one more question
how do you select for edited cells to
avoid amplification
on non-edited cells
yeah so the pool will of course always
have there will be
some cells are edited and some are not
and we do have on the plasmid
we have antibiotic resistance markers
to make sure that we are as long as you
are adding your antibiotics you will
still
have a preference growth of any cell
that harbors
the plasmid so but
ultimately we of course want the
specific edits to be
the growth advantage so
but but at this point in time you can
use antibiotics and grow up with
with these resistance markers in order
to have higher
number of just the overall population
yeah thank you dr clinton for this
excellent q a
session do you have any final comments
for our audience
yeah so so i just want to thank
everybody so much for
for staying today and attending this
webinar and listening
um i just i hope that you felt
this was time well spent and that i just
want to let you know that
we also offer digital seminars with our
science team as well as physical
seminars when the
the whole when it's safe to to travel
again then
we can also come and visit you and do
seminars
so um i just want to encourage everybody
to
write me or uh yeah
and you know if you want that or you can
also go to inscriptor's website
and fill in the contact information if
you are interested
in having any seminar or discussing more
about the technology we are very happy
to
to do so thank you
now before we go i do want to thank our
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions we
did have quite a few questions we were
unable to answer
live today so those questions and
additionally those that are submitted
during the on demand period
they will be addressed by dr clinton via
the email address you provided
at the time of registration i'd once
again like to thank dr laura clinton for
her time today
and her important research we would also
like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor inscripta for
underwriting today's
educational webcast now today's webcast
can be viewed on demand
and labyrinths will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us
and we hope to see you again soon have a
great day
you